hey this is Mel strong and in this
lecture we're going to be talking about
some of the major water projects of the
southwestern United States so the big
picture here is that if we look at a map
of precipitation for the US and we've
seen this map before there's this big
blob of orange and red colors here in
the southwest in if we just kind of drew
a circle kind of a right through around
there there's about 40 million people
living in the driest part of the country
and today's lecture is about how that is
possible so this is more of a history
and maybe a little bit of politics
lecture and less on science so before we
start just imagine the following imagine
if somebody came to you and said you can
continue living here in Albuquerque or
Arizona or wherever you live but the
deal is you can only have the water that
fell from this guy
okay how easy would it be to live here I
mean it would be pretty tough to carve
out a living if you could only use the
water that actually fell as
precipitation right and yet we have the
system that you just turn on the faucet
boom water comes out it's a miracle
question is how did all that come to be
how does it work and when did it happen
and for most of the things we're talking
about today all of this happened before
any of us were born okay this is a
system that was that was started over a
hundred years ago people are still
working on it and we completely depend
on this for to live in in the driest
part of the country so we're gonna start
our story in Los Angeles in fact the big
motivating factor behind what we're
going to be talking about is population
growth so if you go back to 1900 okay
these are the state populations rights
under so New Mexico has you know under
two hundred thousand people in the whole
state
California has one-half million and if
you project forward when this paper came
out it was 2007 so a little over a
hundred years later you can see that
states like California
you know 36 million so their population
didn't just devil didn't quadruple it
didn't he wasn't even ten times it went
up twenty times right and you see that
in a lot of these states that the
population pretty much all these states
the populations increase by way more
than ten times in a hundred years so
you've got all these people living in an
area that's very very dry and so we're
gonna actually start our story in Los
Angeles we're in the late 1800s there
was just a few thousand people living
there and at the time there was a bunch
of real estate investors and they bought
up a bunch of land around Los Angeles
and they thought here's what we're gonna
do we're going to sell this place as a
great place to live and so they went up
to San Francisco in San Francisco at the
time was the biggest city along the west
coast it was this major port city we
just had the gold rush and all that and
so these real estate investors came in
and they said listen aren't you guys
tired of this cold crappy foggy San
Francisco weather well let me tell you
about a great place to live where it's
sunny almost every day it's called Los
Angeles and we've got some property to
sell you and this plan actually worked
in about 30 years
la goes from being a few thousand people
to over a hundred thousand people that
move there at the same time early 1900s
we start to get the very first movies
now today everybody knows where
Hollywood is Hollywood's in Southern
California that's the you know for a
long time has been the movie capital of
the world well why didn't it start there
right I give all the places in the world
or in the United States
why did Hollywood get set up there okay
so if you go back and you watch an old
timey movie like an old silent movie
with an indoor scene like this one so it
looks like they're filming this indoors
but actually there's no roof on this
this is natural light coming in these
old movies they didn't have artificial
lighting yet so the only way they could
film is if you had a sunny day so they
needed a place to to build their studios
where they could have as much natural
light as possible so they could film all
the time and so this area right down
here is a place that is sunny almost
every day of the year why is that review
question why is it so dry why is it so
neat I'm sorry so sunny over here well a
big reason is our old friend the Pacific
subtropical high right so the Pacific
subtropical high is responsible for why
Hollywood is where it is today because
that constant sinking air keeps the sky
clear allowed those old timey movies to
have natural lighting ok so that's how
it all got started
Pacific subtropical high all right so so
lady 200s we go from a few thousand
people to over a hundred thousand people
and at first the people that show up and
live in this area are getting water out
of the local rivers so there's something
called le river a few creeks that feed
it cases the map of it today and that
works for a little while if you have a
few thousand people but by the time you
get to a hundred thousand that's not
enough water to go around and so they
started to drill well so we're gonna
talk a little bit here about groundwater
for a minute so below the ground there
exists a body of water in most places
and this water becomes replenished in
the winter so in this diagram you've got
some topography and this blue represents
water that has soaked in from above so
usually what happens in our part of the
world during the wet season like the
winter along the west coast rain will
fall and will soak down into the ground
and then what most people don't realize
is that the groundwater is actually
moving now the water table itself is is
this surface that's called the water
table and anytime you have a river
that's just where the water table
comes out onto the surface so here's an
idea here's a little diagram of this so
you get what are called recharge areas
these are areas where the precipitation
is added soaks down and then it's
actually on its way
you know it's moving downhill the water
underneath the ground is moving downhill
and ultimately it's headed to the ocean
okay now this shows it moving kind of
left and right towards these rivers but
it's also moving either in or out of the
slide depending on which way is towards
the ocean so what that means is if you
drill down far enough you could get
groundwater like this trying to show a
well that they didn't drill far enough
so it's dry here's one where some water
is kind of piled up here on this barrier
so that when they're getting water out
of point--is for most places in the
world you drill down you'll probably
eventually find some water okay you just
have to drill deep enough so they do
this in Los Angeles and this is a map of
200 large wells that are drilled in
lausanne in the Los Angeles area so
these are not like in your backyard
wells these are wells that are big
enough to supply water to a whole
neighborhood okay so they pump a lot of
water out of the ground well there's a
problem when you start to pump a lot of
water out of the ground so here's the
water table okay so here's some wells
and as they're pumping water out of the
ground you can see that the water table
lowers a little bit by each one of these
wells that's sometimes called a cone of
depression so here they've put in this
you know this is trying to show they put
in this new well here and they're going
to pump a lot and so it pulls down the
water table as they remove water out of
this big high-capacity well and these
guys there well went dry now because the
water table has been lowered
so basically mother nature cannot
replenish the groundwater as fast as the
humans are pulling it out okay so back
to the Los Angeles when they start
pulling the everybody starts printing in
well
at first people are able to pull water
out of the ground but as more and more
people do that
pretty soon the water table all starts
to go down the people wells start to go
dry and they have to read rill those
wells deeper and deeper so here is a
little graph of depth to the water table
okay so now this only starts in 1935 and
our story's starting back in the late
1800s and we don't really have any data
for that but just from 1935 to 1960 what
this is it says ground water elevation
feet from sea level so remember la is
pretty close to sea level okay so what
this means is back then if you drill
down til or a 60 feet above sea level
you hit ground water right but then if
you go ahead to 1945 you had to drill
down until was 40 feet above sea level
and then you had to drill down to sea
level and then you had to drill down to
60 feet below sea level so what's
happening from 1940 to 1960s he is blue
line here
people were have to drill deeper and
deeper and deeper holes just to get to
the groundwater because everybody was
pumping it out faster than mother nature
could replenish it so on average the
groundwater has drop in 8 feet per year
ok well they have an additional problem
in that if you so here's our little cone
of depression here if you pump down the
water table and you happen to live close
to the ocean then sea water will come in
and take the place of the fresh water so
normally before the well was drilled
there was fresh water that was coming
down and Sierra Nevadas in the case of
LA and migrating on this diagram from
left to right and then out into the
ocean so you had constant fresh water
moving underground but once you start
pumping it out and you start removing
the groundwater then salty water will
come back in and replace it and then
people start getting salt in their
groundwater so there's a limit as to how
much groundwater the people in the Los
Angeles could pump out before it started
to go Saul
okay so to recap they took water out of
the river network for a little while
then they started to pump wells that
will work for a little while but they
start to run out of water and realize
that this groundwater solution is only
temporary you can't keep pumping water
out of the ground okay so by 1900 again
we're about a hundred thousand people
there are they're already running into
trouble and they don't have enough well
water they don't have enough river water
what are they gonna do and all these
people have moved here right so this
whole campaign to get people to move
here in Hollywood and all that skin
going and it's clear that people that
want to live in Los Angeles but there's
not enough water so here on this map
here is LA and if you're in one if
you're in my class you had to do this
project trying to find some things on on
the map and one of the things that I
asked you to find was something called
Owens Lake okay and I have owns like
right up here with a little dashed line
so this is Lake that sits up here so
they're thinking about what to do and
someone said well you know here's a
crazy idea what so so the reason this
Lake exists you know this is all desert
by the way this is all desert but
there's a lake up here in the desert and
the reason that Lake is there is because
there's these little streams that come
out of the mountains out of the Sierras
and they drain down into Owens Lake so
what if we captured those streams and
instead of allowing the streams to fill
the lake we we laid this giant pipe all
the way from this lake all the way to
Los Angeles and we'll just take that
stream water and we'll redirect it to LA
okay sounds crazy but that's what they
did and so they decided this you know
this again this is a lady to her
hundreds early 1900s when they're
thinking about this they're gonna start
this giant project to take water that
should be going into Owens Lake and
bring it all the way across the desert
to Los Angeles so we don't have a lot of
pictures
Owens like from back then this is one of
them so here you can see we've got the
Sierras here in the background you see
this body of water here okay this is
about 1900 there's some mining town or
something here up and up in the
foreground here and they're going to
form what's called the LA aqueduct that
is this red line that runs from Owens
Lake all the way down to Los Angeles
so again if you're one of my students I
have put up a map with all the things
I'm showing you okay it's all on it's
all on learn so you can so you can go
and see this print them out whatever
whatever you want to do so the LA
aqueduct huge project they started this
thing in 1908 223 miles of pipe were
laid to take water from Owens Lake all
the way to LA they finish it in 1913
realize at the time what they're dealing
with in terms you know cars hadn't
really been invented I mean a little bit
but not so much pretty much everything
is doing is with you know mule teams
there's no electricity there's no
tractors and they're doing this big
project right so it was a pretty
significant thing to build so here is
another old picture again there's Owens
Lake in the background and here's this
concrete conduit that's the LA aqueduct
so what's gonna flow in the bottom of
this ditch and in here it kind of looks
like the oils that we have around here
in Albuquerque is water that's supposed
to be flowing into the lake but instead
is headed south then from this concrete
ditch this is what it looks like today
okay so that's water that's on its way
to LA it will go into these pipes so
these are the pieces that were these big
pieces they were brought made in Germany
and brought in the you can still see see
them today there they are going across
the desert floor they go up mountains
oops they go down mountains they go
across the desert through towns across
freeways and then eventually that water
comes down into the LA basin so this
thing right here it's like a bunch of
little stairs
that's water coming down into Los
Angeles so the guy that I was in charge
of this is William Mulholland and
Mulholland is this kind of famous name
in LA there's Mulholland Drive and
you'll hear songs and movies referencing
Mulholland so that guy was he was in
charge of this project and in the 1980s
there was a pretty famous book written
called Cadillac desert and it goes into
detail about this and some of the other
water projects were talking about and
PBS in the mid 90s put out this big
mini-series on Cadillac desert and I
think it was like like nine hours long
something like that and for whatever
reason they never released it as an
actual video that you can watch today so
the only parts of it that exist are
parts that were recorded on VCRs back in
the 90s and uploaded to YouTube so the
quality is really really poor and I'm
just gonna show you a couple minutes of
a clip of them building the LA aqueduct
so again I apologize the quality is
pretty poor it's the only thing we
really have today so I'm going to show
that real quick here
[Music]
it was a great drama it was a great epic
drama of the building of that aqueduct
do you have mule teams and you have men
they were working in desert heat arid
conditions water was a problem
ironically enough here in this giant
water project they had they had to worry
about adequate water for the working
stock and the men
it can be almost freezing it at night
and then 110 degrees in the daytime
practically maja was there all the time
chief engineer Mulholland had no formal
training in civil engineering he had in
fact never graduated from grade school
the automobile had barely been invented
clipper ships were still sailing the
seas and this was an engineering project
the likes of which the world had really
never seen before
Mulholland ordered two 12-foot steel
pipe forged in Germany and shipped
around the horn a hundred thousand men
and women worked on the aqueducts but
never more than a few thousand at a time
because the exhausting and dangerous
work kept turnover so high they had been
farmhands cowboys and hard rock miners
but now they were city employees civil
servants like the chief himself with no
air-conditioning no refrigeration no
hard hats in 110 degree heat
they crossed the Mojave in five years
with a pipe big enough to hold a
locomotive
this was you know an aqueduct that would
have reached all the way across
Massachusetts and then almost all the
way back through a desert with mountains
what they were really building was was
the world's largest garden hose surveyor
said they could build the aqueduct
simply by following the trail of whiskey
bottles Mulholland and Eaton had thrown
off the back of their buckboard in 1904
in the end the chief and his lieutenants
finished the job under budget and ahead
of schedule
William Mulholland built his original
aqueduct so well that to this day it
still carries the Owens River to the
people of Los Angeles
the phrase Grandpa's aqueduct will
remind my first words
the day of the dedication of the
aqueduct was without a doubt the high
point of my grandfather's life
a crowd of 30 to 40,000 Los Angelenos
had gathered at the base of the spillway
there was a formal program but once the
water spilled down the Cascade the
formal program was abandoned because
thousands of people rushed with their
tin cups to drink the water
[Music]
when the water came cascading down there
Mahal and who was really exhausted at
the time gave what I think is the most
concise dedication speech in history he
unfurled an American flag he turned to
the water and he said there it is taken
[Applause]
based on Mulholland predictions it was
four times more water than Los Angeles
could use so you probably figured out
that was mo Holland's granddaughter in
that in that movie
the other thing they wanted you to pay
attention to is in the opening ceremony
yeah the release the water comes down
the spillway and all that and Mulholland
says this is four times the amount of
water that Los Angeles is ever going to
need so keep that in mind okay
so they take the waters that are
supposed to be going into Owens Lake
they redirect them to LA what happens to
the lake dries up okay so if you're one
of my students and you're trying to find
Owens Lake on the map you may have had
some trouble because the lake no longer
exists here we can see where it was this
big brown spot used to be full of water
okay and notice what's around right this
is pretty dry sagebrush we're in a
pretty dry area and you can see from
space
where the lake used to be so this again
kind of light-colored spot right there
and this lake was pretty important to
the environment because when you have a
lake sitting out here in the desert it's
super important for all kinds of
organisms to survive out there and that
includes those that live around the lake
plus a lot of the migratory animals that
stopped there to refuel and
what-have-you before they move on so you
know a lot of migratory birds for
example used to stop at Owens Lake on
their way one way or the other and now
they can't do that because that Lake is
no longer
there so this is you know there was a
complete collapse of the ecosystem
around from the disappearance of Lake
Owens and you'll notice here that this
so this is what it looks like today
these are all mostly kind of salts that
were left behind after the lake dried up
see this kind of white if you walk on
this is kind of white crunchy texture to
it and when the wind blows it blows up
dust from this lake bed now if you
remember a few lectures ago on air
pollution we said that particulate
matter PM is one of the regulated
pollutants that we keep track of in this
country from the Clean Air Act so in the
80s the EPA goes to the city of Los
Angeles and says see all this PM that's
your guys's fault okay cuz you caused
this lake to dry up and now the winds
blow and that dust and you're
responsible so la says okay here's what
we're going to do we will drill a well
and we're going to install sprinklers on
the bottom oh it used to be the lake bed
so they're irrigating the bottom of the
dried-up lake bed to prevent the dust
from blowing all this PM up into the air
okay that's their solution there's been
a few attempts to try to reintroduce a
little bit of water into the lake to try
to get some of the wildlife to come back
you can see this little sector here has
a little bit of water in it when I say a
little bit it's literally just a few
inches of deep right so all the white
area that's that's the salty spots again
so a little bit but not enough to really
bring it back to anywhere where in the
status it used to be well that works for
a while and we get to 1930 and the
population of LA has increased tenfold
again to over a million people and oh
look we're out of water so no it wasn't
four times the amount of water that la
would need thirty years or so later
they're already out of water so what are
they gonna do so they look around on the
map and I said well
here's a crazy idea way up north there's
another Lake Cod Mono Lake how about we
do this same game plan and we extend our
aqueduct up here and take the water
that's supposed to be going into Mono
Lake so this is the plan and what they
do is they extend that aqueduct that
went up to Owens Lake and they continue
on this red line here in a 1941 they get
all the way to Mono Lake and they start
taking the waters that are supposed to
be going into Mono Lake well this is
what Mono Lake looks like today now it
has not dried up yet and we'll talk
about why in a second but you can see
the lake used to be a lot bigger you can
see where the old shorelines used to be
out here
these are islands that used to be
underwater
okay so it used to me about twice as big
as it is today well it was drying up and
in fact by the time you get to about
1960 or so the volume of the lake had
halved and the salinity had doubled so
you see in this body of water it's twice
as salty as it was before and animals
are having trouble surviving things are
starting to die out and it looks like to
everybody that the whole ecosystem is
collapsing just like Owens Lake did
right so a bunch of citizens got
together and they cited before this lake
completely dries up like Owens Lake
we're gonna fight this in court and they
got together and they sued city of Los
Angeles and there was in the 1970s
there's something called the Mono Lake
committee citizens and some scientists
got together and started these lawsuits
to try to slow the destruction of Mono
Lake and it goes to court and after
several years they decided that they
said okay he the court decision
essentially was if I go back here
la is allowed to take water
but they cannot allow the lake to go
below a certain level which is the level
you see here in this picture so it's not
going to get any deeper it's not gonna
get any fuller but it's also not
supposed to go down anymore okay so
that's the ruling that came out and
again this was 70s and 80s when this
happens and so that you know that was a
result of citizens just getting together
and suing and trying to prevent this
whole ecosystem from collapsing in the
same way that Owens Lake did okay well
by time he gets in 1960 the population
has now doubled since 1930 when they
started to go to Mono Lake and again
they're out of water right so another
solution they come up with is to double
up the aqueduct and so there's a second
LA aqueduct that goes parallel to the
first one so on this picture this is the
first one that pipe right there that's
the second one okay over here there's
the first one there is a second one so
they just have two pipes right next to
each other going right up to Lake Owens
so that they can take twice as much
water so from LA up to Owens Lake
there's actually two pipes next to each
other and then there's only one that
goes the rest of the way to Mono Lake
okay well Ellie's out of water still
after going to Owens Lake after going to
Mono Lake after doubling up the
aqueducts after getting the water out of
the rivers after getting the well water
so they start looking around right well
you know what there's a nice little
river over here called the Colorado sure
would be nice would take if we could
take some water out of that so this
brings up an important point which is
who legally is able to take water out of
a river if the river is shared between
several states so this is the Colorado
River starts in Colorado up up up here
off the map actually comes down through
from Colorado through Utah through
Arizona it's on the border
between Arizona and Nevada it's also on
the border between Arizona and
California it goes to Mexico goes out
into the Gulf of California so here's
the problem let's say Arizona says ok so
in case you didn't know this is the
Grand Canyon right here right so what's
preventing Arizona from saying we're
gonna put in a giant dam right here or
we're gonna block the water we're gonna
make this giant we're gonna fill the
whole Grand Canyon full of water and
we're just going to keep it and nobody
downstream is going to get any of it so
none of it goes to California so what's
preventing Arizona from doing that
because technically any state on the
river here could put up some kind of dam
and everybody downstream would would
suffer right so States realized they got
to figure something now this is about a
hundred years ago and they're thinking
about this so what they decide is that
if you are part of what's called the
Colorado River watershed you are
entitled to a portion of the Colorado
River water now what is a watershed so
all of these little red lines are Little
rivers and little creeks that ultimately
go into the Colorado River right so if
you are raindrop and you fall and you
land in this red zone anywhere here
you'll end up in the Colorado River
that's the watershed ok this whole area
are all these rivers that ultimately
feed the Colorado River we're gonna zoom
in a little bit here so the Colorado
River itself doesn't even go through New
Mexico for example right it's over here
ok and it goes this way
but here we are here's New Mexico and
notice that we have some of those little
red lines over here so we have a bunch
of little creeks that ultimately flow to
the west and end up in the Colorado
River so what this means is states like
ours we don't have the Colorado River
but because our little streams feed the
Colorado River we
are legally entitled to a portion of the
Colorado River water as are all the
states that have a little bit of these
red lines okay including California now
California has a pretty tiny measly
amount of watershed right it's just like
a couple little chunks of red line here
that's the only thing that feeds the
Colorado River and they're in the desert
anyway so that's not a lot of water but
technically they're allowed to have some
of the Colorado River water well they
decided that what they're going to do is
they're going to split up all of these
states into what we call upper basin
States and lower Basin States so these
are all states that are part of that
watershed they all legally get some
water okay but they're gonna subdivide
and again here's that little bit though
of California here but they're gonna sub
you're gonna subdivide the Colorado
River water up between all of the states
that have part of this either upper
basin or lower basin shading okay so all
these states get something so in 1922 a
bunch of politicians get together to
hash out what's called the Colorado
River Compact the Colorado River Compact
is like a treaty among instead of treaty
among nations as a treaty among states
and they decide okay we're gonna figure
out who gets what now is it evenly
divided based on the watershed know who
gets the most amount of water California
gets the biggest amount of water even
though they have a very tiny portion of
the watershed but they had the biggest
population so they had most political
weight when this is all decided there's
a unit here capital am capital a FY that
stands for million acre feet per year
what does that mean an acre imagine a
football field okay now imagine a
football field that you flood with
twelve inches of water a foot so now
you've got a flooded football field with
a foot of water on it that's called an
acre foot of water now imagine
you can't really but a million of those
that's a million acre-feet okay so what
this is saying is that Colorado you get
three point eight eight six million
acre-feet per year and Nevada you get
point three million acre-feet per year
so this is all hashed out in 1922 now
how did they come up with these numbers
well what they did is they went and they
surveyed the Colorado River and they
wanted to figure out how much water does
the Colorado River deliver okay so in
1922 they go out with a bunch of gauges
and they're measuring how much flow was
coming down the Colorado and then they
look at that number and they divide it
up between all these states well we now
know there was a problem with that 1922
was an unusually wet year and we've had
very few years since then as wet as 1922
so all of these numbers are based on an
unusually wet year which means that
today on a normal drier year that these
numbers cannot be obtained but there's a
treaty in 1922 that says each state gets
to have this much water so right away
out of the gate we get a problem because
the states are now fighting each other
that they're not getting their fair
share of water we are we've been in the
drought we'll talk about this later for
many years in the southwest which means
that these numbers are much lower than
you know much much lower than they were
in 1922 so this is a cause for friction
in in the southwest because everybody
wants to the water they're legally
entitled to it but there's just not
enough to go around okay
so once that's hashed out in 1922 and it
races okay you get this much do you get
this much do you get this much now
people can start building dams and
taking water out of the Colorado River
okay so again if you're one of my
students we on your map I had you find
some of these dams and sand outline some
of these reservoirs and again I have put
a map on learn with what these features
on there
one of the very first dams major dams
that's get gets built is Hoover Dam okay
which is now next to modern-day Las
Vegas this is what Hoover Dam looks like
before they built it as the site of
Hoover Dam you see how these rock
there's that there's a narrow kind of a
v-shape here whenever they're trying to
build a dam they're looking for a spot
where the River narrows because it makes
it easier to build across this so
they're gonna fill up this V in this
Canyon with concrete and that's gonna be
Hoover Dam so here they are building it
this is in the 30s kind of a
depression-era project puts a lot of
people to work and here's what it looks
like when it's done so this is the
Colorado River now it's stuck behind
this wall that's over dam and notice
these towers here okay and I'm going to
show you another picture of referencing
these towers in a second so they build
this dam 1935 and the Colorado River
comes up behind it and gets stuck and
starts to fill up with water and that's
going to become Lake Mead so here we are
filling up the dam here's those four
towers again and here's what it looks
like when it's full there's the four
towers all the ones off the picture this
is one of the few times that Lake Mead
was full in fact it's flowing over this
this overspill area right here this is
in the 1980s and then usually what time
turns out it's almost never ever ever
looks like this okay this is what it
looks like when like me and is actually
full so the lake you realize was formed
by just flooding the river that was
behind the dam right so we the river was
coming along and doing its own thing we
fill this up with concrete and now the
water starts to build up behind it so
this is gonna make a lake but it's a
weird Lake like normally if you if you
explain if you tell somebody I'm going
to go up to a lake they're kind of
visualizing usually something kind of
roundish but we're making artificial
lakes here by putting a dam up and and
so we're flooding a what used to be a
river and it just floods it up straight
and makes a makes a very unusual shaped
lake and here you can see those how dry
this is okay what if you haven't been to
Las Vegas you know what's it like
this is temperatures routinely over 100
degrees in the summer the relative
humidity is a few percent routinely
here's like Mead winding out into the
distance rakes this is just this was a
river valley but now it's full of water
look how dry it is right nothing nothing
growing here at all
what's the evaporation rate do you think
you got temperatures over a hundred
degrees routinely relative humidity
single percent big surface area right
big surface area you're losing a lot of
water to to evaporation and so you're in
this area that's super dry you're
building dams to store water because you
want water to live where it's super dry
but you're also losing a lot of it
through evaporation
well once Lake Mead is built or if sorry
once Hoover Dam is built and the Lake
Mead is their loss and Las Vegas was
this little tiny nothing in 1930 this is
the whole city but now you've got a
source of water the dam is producing
electricity so yeah source electricity
prohibition ends and also we had a
moratorium on gambling most people don't
know this but back prohibition days you
couldn't gamble either and so all those
things
prohibition ends gambling is legal you
got a source of water you got
electricity Las Vegas just explodes
right
and so water use in Las Vegas explodes
along with it so here's a population and
this is in thousands so so a thousand
thousand is a million right so the
population is going up that's these dots
right and then as it goes up the water
consumption goes up to in millions of
gallons per day now this is coming out
of the groundwater there
so they're using groundwater whether
they can they're using water out of Lake
Mead because it's there and they're
legally entitled to some of it but of
course the water is very much needed for
very important things like the Bellagio
fountains right you've got to have that
do you think there's any evaporation
going on here you're throwing little
droplets of water up into a hundred plus
degree air with relative humidities and
single digits how much water do you
suppose they're losing here just an
evaporation or maybe you need to use
that water for other very important
things like golf courses and I
especially like this picture to show the
stark contrast between the super dry
desert here in the background and the
heavily irrigated Golf Course right next
to it so that's where a lot of this
water ends up going out of the Colorado
River
so that is Hoover Dam and Lake Mead
right we go upstream we go through the
Grand Canyon go through the Grand Canyon
go through the Grand Canyon and we get
up here and there's another dam called
the Glen Canyon Dam and behind the Glen
Canyon Dam is Lake Powell so same idea
the Colorado River was coming through
here minding its own business we put up
this big dam we block it the river
canyon floods and so now we have this
big funny windy looking lake called Lake
Powell which is just a flooded river
canyon so it's this weird windy looking
thing well glen canyon dam was built at
a time when this was in the 50s and
there's actually a significant amount of
protests around building this dam and
the reason for that is because glen
canyon itself was a canyon that people
actually like to visit it was kind of an
extension of the Grand Canyon so the
picture on the right is what it looked
like before they flooded it so all this
water is flooding this Canyon right
there's water up to the top of this
canyon at least there is in this picture
this is what it looked like this is what
they flooded and there's a significant
number
people who thought this is a really bad
idea because this is a really beautiful
place it's one of the nicest places in
the world to go you can go rafting you
go fishing you can go camping and we
don't want to lose this we don't want to
flood it like this doesn't make any
sense and people fought this and so
these pictures I'm showing you are what
it looked like before the dam was built
so these are all pictures from the 1950s
or before so you can see it's a pretty
nice place right I mean it carrying
mines you of the Grand Canyon it's it's
similar to to the Grand Canyon except
it's now all underwater people used to
go rafting slot canyons the whole thing
here they are starting to build the dam
the dam is going to go right here okay
so that Canyon behind us that's going to
be filled with water now an interesting
point to this story is that because
we've had a lot of drought in the last
20 years in the southwest that Lake
Powell is no longer up to the top like I
showed you in those earlier pictures and
as the lake has been receding it's
revealing some of the original Canyon
not like it used to be but you you're
starting to actually see a canyon again
so that's an example where some you know
groups got together they fought the
formation of a dam didn't work out it's
dam was still built there are still
groups today fighting to get the dam
removed okay so this is I mean I don't
think they have a very good chance of
this but there's still people are still
trying to get that damn removed worth
pointing out that there was also another
dam that was going to go up somewhere
around in here kind of in the middle of
between Hoover Dam and Glen Canyon Dam
and that one was also fought and that
one was dropped so we could have had
another dam that would have floated a
good portion of the Grand Canyon and our
predecessors thankfully I think fought
that and per invented that so we
actually have the Grand Canyon as it is
today
so we're going to talk a little bit
about some of the problems of putting
dams on a river like the Colorado and
let's just imagine that we had you know
think about a river going down a slope
and the water is coming down doing what
rivers do and then what I'm gonna do is
put up this dam and the water is going
to accumulate behind the dam fill up and
produce a reservoir right and then I'm
gonna have some way of releasing a
little bit of water out the bottom that
continues on down the stream right so
that's the system that we have in place
so what's the problem with that so one
of the biggest problems is if you are an
organism like a fish and you are trying
to say get from here to here you've got
a problem because you've got this big
dam structure in the way okay and some
fish really need to migrate that's part
of their natural life cycle so salmon
are a classic example so salmon start
start their life out up in a very
shallow slow-moving Creek and they lay
eggs okay and then the parents die off
and the eggs hatch in the spring and you
got a little baby salmon with you guys
and they grow in this river again a very
slow moving River usually for a couple
years and then when they get big enough
they migrate downstream and they head
towards the ocean
so they come out into the ocean and
they'll spend years out in the ocean
swimming around doing whatever salmon do
late in life they come back to the same
river that they came out of and we don't
know how they do this they must they
must every River must have a unique
chemical signature that they can detect
somehow but they'll go back and find the
same river they came from and they'll go
upstream
so they gotta go up the river now and so
whenever you see pictures of salmon
jumping trying to get up little rapids
or waterfalls they're trying to get back
to the place where they were born now go
all the way back to the place where they
were born they find a mate they lay eggs
and then they die and the whole process
starts again
right so this is what salmon do so if
you put up a dam in the middle of that
whole process
you've just prevented this whole
lifecycle from taking place
right which is a major bummer if you're
a salmon trying to make a living now
there's a few things that have been done
to try to mitigate this namely something
called fish ladders so the dam is over
here okay and so just to orient you so
there's a there's a stream that would be
kind of behind us so before the dam was
in place the salmon would come this way
and then they just go upstream to where
you know this concrete would not have
been there originally and they just go
up to where they need to go but now this
concrete's here so what they have is you
can see these little look like little
steps
that's a fish ladder and so the salmon
figure out that there's water coming
down this way so they instinctively go
up and they go up all the way these
through these steps up up up up up up up
and then they jump off and they land on
the other side of the dam that's a fish
ladder and there are places where you
can actually kind of watch this in
action so here's a salmon trying to jump
the stairs of a fish ladder and there's
you see a bunch of them trying to get up
the fish ladder so it kind of works
definitely some salmon are able to
return home through fish ladders and
keep going but a big problem you have is
with oxygenation so back in my picture
of this dam here if this fills with
water the water down here is very
stagnant okay and because it's very
stagnant has very little oxygen
and dams are designed to release water
out at the bottom so the water that
comes out of the bottom of this dam also
has little oxygen now that's not true
with the water that goes into the dam
right you've got Rapids
you've got fast-moving water gurgling
bubbling there's a lot of oxygen in
there it fills up this reservoir and
stagnates and that little oxygen water
comes out goes down stream so any
animals that are down here are stuck in
this water that has relatively little
oxygen a lot of them don't like that
sometimes your deoxygenation can get to
the point that fish actually die so this
is here we're in the dam okay so now
we're we're talking about fish living in
this part in the reservoir and the
oxygen level got so low that a whole
bunch of fish died and usually happens
overnight so during the day there's some
photosynthesis that's helping
reoxygenate the water but then
respiration is happening all night long
and that's when your oxygen level goes
down so this can happen if you don't
have enough oxygen in your reservoirs
the deep water also is colder so this
water that comes out down here not only
is low oxygen but it's cold and again
we're thinking about the animals that
lived in the in the water before the dam
was built they are used to pretty
shallow pretty fast-moving water which
is oxygenated and warmer than what's
coming out of the dam right so what's
coming out of the dam now is colder it
has less oxygen and a lot of the animals
just can't survive in that the other
weird thing is that this water up here
at the very top of the dam is actually
warmer than it normally is it's stagnant
there's isn't there's not a lot of
mixing the Sun's up every day and it's
warming the the top layer of that water
and so for example you take something
like this Glen Canyon Dam is we've seen
this picture before
Canyon Dam and Lake Powell and this used
to be a fast-moving river which is now
just pretty stagnant and you go from the
water that was in the Glen Canyon Dam or
I'm sorry in Glen Canyon before the dam
and you can see it's kind of choppy and
it's aerated and could cooler
temperature compared to the surface of
what's on lake powell today and see how
all those green stuff that's algae
analogy is happy in this environment
where there's not a lot of motion and
it's relatively warm because we're
talking about water at the top of the
lake now not the bottom the bottom is
called but the top isn't is warm so this
is what it looks like now this is what
when we built that dam Glen Canyon Dam
we transformed this kind of water to
this kind of water and that's again
because it's stagnant it has really warm
along the surface they prevent sediment
from moving downstream okay so if you've
got sediment coming down normally coming
down it's being washed down and it heads
out to the ocean but what happens is it
starts to pile up behind the dam okay
now why would that be important if you
look at the mouth of a normal River so
here comes here comes the river dumping
out into the ocean you can see all this
mud and you can see in the water that it
has this brown or color this is sediment
and this sediment is actually really
needed by a lot of the ecosystems
downstream from where the dam is is
built so here's a couple of examples so
here's our dam and here's the sediments
that are accumulated behind the dam and
the water is coming out so at first the
water is flowing where it used to okay
but because we are keeping the sediment
trap back here that River will start to
cut down into the surrounding rock and
there's no sediment to come back and
rebuild anything so what happens is the
river starts actually cutting down
word into the landscape
now when the river cuts down the other
thing that happens is it the water table
also goes down with it so let's say in
this scenario we had a river that was
kind of near the surface here but and we
had some trees let's just draw here
let's say we've got some trees growing
kind of by the river and they have a
root system
okay the root system comes down like
this okay now as the river cuts down
right as the river cuts down into the
surrounding country eventually the water
table goes down with it and the roots
which used to be able to get ground
water from the surrounding river now are
dry because the river has now cut down
below where the root systems are okay so
that so I'm exaggerating this to
illustrate a point but if the sediment
is blocked then the river cuts cuts down
cuts down cuts down water table drops
with it and eventually you can drop far
enough down that some vegetation
downstream will eventually die because
it can get water so therefore if you
block sediment then the river downstream
well you wrote away case we just talked
about that rivers downstream cut down
deeper than they used to
okay so we talked about that and the
water table lowers downstream and
vegetation can die okay so those things
can happen by just blocking the
sediments from going downstream now
everything we've been talking about is
how the natural animals and plant life
don't like these changes they don't like
though the water that might be cold or
has less oxygen or whatever or there's
something that will right if you set up
an artificial lake essentially and you
change the temperature and you change
the oxygen and there's some other
organism that's actually going to thrive
in that and they're going to get into
these lakes and they're going to do well
and you're going to
an invasive species problem on your
hands so by building dams and building
these artificial reservoirs
we're setting up situations environments
for innovate invasive species to come in
and wreak havoc on the natural ecosystem
if you are in my class you had to
identify a few major dams on a few
rivers but realize there's a lot more
than what the ones that we're talking
about here so on the map that we're
using in my class which again is on
learn or on my website here's a number
of dams in various states which means
that there's over 5,000 dams that are on
that map I just had to identify a
handful of them they're all different
sizes right so they're not as always big
as Hoover Dam some of them they're just
a little structure just right underneath
the water that you wouldn't even notice
if you're standing there looking at it
and some are these giant you know
concrete structures so pretty much every
water system River Creek whatever you
want to call it is under control now
that we have everything pretty much
dammed up and we as humans control when
the rivers flow when they don't flow
when they're allowed to flood etc
there's very few waterways left in fact
in the United States in general that are
actually naturally flowing anymore so
one thing that is on your map is
something called the Continental Divide
and the Continental Divide here is shown
as the margin of this these two areas
that lower Basin an upper basin
what's the Continental Divide that's
supposed to be the place in the country
where if you're a raindrop and you fall
on the east side of the Continental
Divide you will eventually flow to the
east and into the Atlantic Ocean or
maybe the Gulf of Mexico
if you range up and you fall on this
side of the Continental Divide you flow
to the west and you end up in the
Pacific or you end up in the Gulf of
California okay
ask Continental Divide well Continental
Divide is a natural
boundary between where water drains
right but there are several instances
where humans would like to take water
from one side of the Continental Divide
and bring it over to the other and
Colorado is one of those places so
Colorado is entitled to a portion of the
Colorado River water that's part of the
1922 agreement where are all the people
in Colorado
well Denver is over here and the rivers
are over here now before Denver they
still wanted water over here for
agricultural reasons right there's a lot
of reasons you might want to have water
over here but it's draining the wrong
way so what do you do you well what they
decided to do is they've decided to
drill tunnels through the mountains in
something called a trans mountain
diversion trans mountain diversion means
the natural flow of the water is it's
going to go on one side of the mountain
but what we're going to do is we're
going to put in some tunnels and we're
going to redirect it through the other
side okay so if you go in Colorado
you'll find some of these diversion
tunnels in this water just literally
going through a tunnel and through a
mountain coming out the other side this
is water that's supposed to go in the
Colorado River Colorado decided that
what they wanted to do with their
Colorado River water is directed through
under underground through the mountains
and out the other side you know over
towards in direction of Denver okay so
all of those things are happening along
the Colorado River we're building dams
we got trans mountain diversions let's
go back to our friends in California
remember they were running out of water
over and over and over and they were
looking towards the Colorado and after
1922 and that treaty has passed they're
now allowed to take water from the
Colorado and so there's a little dam
that's on your map called Parker dam and
it backs up the Colorado to this lake
called Lake Havasu and if you go there
this is what it looks like okay so
there's a lake havasu in the back and
you notice there's water that kind of
goes
off to the left here that goes into a
canal that's called the Colorado
aqueduct and it takes water from the
Colorado River across the desert and
into Los Angeles this is what it looks
like so it's a concrete lined ditch for
the most part and the water goes across
the desert and into modern-day Los
Angeles as it makes its way there there
are opportunities for farmers to get
water out of that and this is one of the
early promotional traveling exhibits for
the water that's coming to Los Angeles
and this helped build up the
agricultural areas around there well if
there is a worse place to build a city
than Las Vegas it might be Phoenix okay
so it's just as hot as Las Vegas or
hotter it's far away from any bodies of
water out in the middle Arizona and so
Phoenix is also having its own water
difficulties and just like in California
and all these places we're talking about
they've been running out of ground water
so this is not a great graphic this as
approximate decline in groundwater
levels from 1940 to 1995 so this is
we're looking at feet so - 150 - 200 -
50 that's how far the water groundwater
level has dropped so what that means is
if you lived saying in the bullseye you
have to drill down 200 feet deeper in
1995 to hit water than you did in 1940
and what happens is as the groundwater
goes down and down and down at some
point it just becomes impractical to
actually be able to drill a hole that
deep and extract water the other problem
that they're having in Phoenix is that
they've been pumping so much groundwater
out of the ground for so long that the
ground is starting to sink and so here's
a map of what we call a subsidence of of
the ground
so it says land surface displacement and
the numbers are in centimeters so red
means - 15 centimeters so this number
here that's -12 that means the ground
has literally sunk 12 centimeters
between 1996 and the year 2000 right so
in 4 years this is how much recorded
subsidence how much did the ground sink
right and so you see this whole area
here has been sinking and as a result of
the area sinking there are these really
strange fissures opening up around
Phoenix because the ground is all
sinking as they suck up all this ground
water and these big fissures have been
opening up all around so they need water
right and they are entitled to Colorado
River water so in fact if you go back to
Parker dam which is when we just saw
there is another project another canal
that takes water from that dam from the
Colorado River goes all across the
Arizona desert and goes into Phoenix and
then actually about last 10 years or so
they've extended it all the way to get
into Tucson this is how Phoenix can
continue to survive in one of the
hottest driest places in the country
called the central Arizona Project and
here's what it looks like right just
weird like this artificial river going
through the desert and I like this
picture because here we are in central
Arizona and yet oh look we have golf
courses how could that be
you can see the the canal right next to
it with all the water coming from the
Colorado River another picture here okay
well California is not done and in fact
if you go further south so that we've
been looking at Parker dam we go all the
way down to there's another little tiny
dam called an imperial dam and coming
off of Imperial dam something called the
All American canal I don't know exactly
who named it but it's ironic
that's right on the border with Mexico
right right over here the all-american
canal and you see it branches up there's
a whole bunch of branches that come off
of this and there's actually hundreds of
them I just drew a few of them on here
if you would look at a satellite image
of this part of the world
so there's Central Valley of California
okay and it's kind of green and there
are dams in Northern California that
bring water down and irrigate a lot of
the fields plus they have a lot of wells
there and they didn't notice it gets
super dry right this is super dry we're
in the desert here and then notice down
here there's a blob of green there and
blob of green there on the zoom in this
blob of green right here there's that's
the international boundary border right
here this is called the Imperial Valley
this and this and if you look right
there on if you can tell this or not
yeah these are sand dunes and this is
what it looks like okay so this is a
picture taken from that spot right there
okay this is how dry this area is
supposed to be remember we're in the
area of the Pacific subtropical high for
a big portion of the year very dry very
hot you see nothing green in this
picture
right but by bringing in water for this
all-american canal you can see it right
there comes right through here and then
this whole Green Zone is one of the
richest agricultural areas in the world
very likely you have eaten something
today that has come from this area
called the Imperial Valley and here
comes the all-american canal going
through the sand dunes on its way
through the desert until we get to this
you can see you're super dry mountains
in the distance very green fields up
ahead and all of these green fields here
are being watered with Colorado River
water it's a perfect
to grow crops it's sunny almost every
day it's warm the soil is good you just
don't have any water problem solved
we've got the all-american canal
bringing in water down from the Colorado
River so that's what's happening here
and my question then is okay if if the
Colorado River comes down and crosses
into Mexico and then goes in dumps into
the Gulf of California after we divert
it through all these different canals
and all these different dams and
what-have-you
what what's left when it crosses the
border and what's left when it goes into
the Gulf of California so I'm gonna look
we're gonna zoom in right in here here's
the international border right there
this is the path of the Colorado and I'm
gonna zoom in here for you and I'm gonna
zoom in a little bit more right here
zoom in a little more
that's the Colorado River notice there's
no River right you can see where people
in spending donuts out here in the in
the dust the Colorado River has not
reached the ocean since 1983 except for
a couple exceptions to that where they
released a little bit of water so the
Colorado River a hundred percent of the
river is used up by people so and all
these different water projects were
talking about the Colorado River split
up all these different ways and if you
remember when we started talking about
this I said that 1922 is a record wet
year and nobody gets the amount of water
they want everybody's arguing about it
none of it gets to the ocean anymore in
that ecosystem from Neal from here South
all the way in New Mexico that whole
ecosystem around the river completely
collapsed right because that all that
water just got turned off so where the
Colorado River has that 1922 agreement
there was a similar agreement for the
Rio Grande
the Rio Grande compact and the Rio
Grande itself starts out up here in
Colorado then comes down through New
Mexico and forms the border between
Texas and Mexico right and so there's
three American states that share the
river and so there is a legal agreement
as to how much each state gets from that
River and so we also have several dams
along the Rio Grande River and so if i
zoom in a little bit so here comes the
Rio Grande kinda makes this Big Bend as
it goes into New Mexico here's one
Cochiti if you're from around here you
might be familiar with Cochiti dam here
comes the river and the river continues
down here and there's the earthen dam
Cochiti dam was built in the 70s and
initially it was supposed to be a much
bigger reservoir than what you see in
this picture in fact if you look at this
it looks like it needs a lot more water
in it partly that's the drought partly
because when they built this they kind
of screwed up
and it turns out that if you put too
much water in this reservoir over here
it comes boiling out of the ground over
here and that's because they didn't
study the subsurface geology correctly
so this dam this reservoir will never
get any higher really than what you see
in this in these pictures but people
still use it and so Cochiti dam is is is
is up here
Albuquerque's right there and you need
go all the way down here in the southern
part of the state you can get to a
couple of dams that are also pretty well
known in particular Elephant Butte dam
and Elephant Butte reservoir is actually
a pretty old reservoir today after the
Rio Grande compact its centrally like a
holding pond for Texas meaning that
Texas is legally entitled to a certain
portion of the Rio Grande water
and we as New Mexicans have to be able
to deliver to them when they want that's
part of the agreement
so Elephant Butte is you know the
reservoir itself is water that is
waiting to go to Texas and then when
they say we need them you know we need a
hundred thousand acre feet we send it on
down to them okay we've been in a
drought situation for a long time and
you can kind of see by the rings on this
rock here that the lake level should be
a lot higher than it is in fact it's
only been a bit like a few percent full
for the last several years now one of
the problems is similar to Lake Mead
here you have desert area it's hot it's
dry low relative humidity lots of
surface area right so how much are we
losing in evaporation each year a lot
right and if we're giving in legal
trouble with Texas because if we don't
have enough water to send the Texas and
we can get fined we have to pay them and
who wants to pay Texas so we have to
have a way to prevent losing so much
water and people have been working on
like what what could we do to prevent
all this evaporation and so this sounds
crazy but one idea might be to cover the
entire lake with like ping-pong balls
now these are not ping-pong balls
they're bigger this is a reservoir in
California where they're they've been
they've had a water crisis there forever
and they decided that they would cover
the entire lake with these plastic balls
and it forms a layer and prevents
evaporation rate so we might have to do
something like that with a Elephant
Butte someday now here's a magazine ad
this is pretty low quality it's the only
one I can find it says name a great
American city on a large body of water
and it shows a guy windsurfing out here
and you look at those buildings in the
background and I know it's a really
crappy image but is there anything back
there you might recognize because this
is supposed to be a picture
downtown Albuquerque and it may seem
crazy to us now but there is a time when
they were advertising people to please
come here because we have so much water
yeah we're in a desert but guess what
underneath Albuquerque huge amounts of
groundwater so much groundwater is as
much as a great lake much as Lake Erie
something like that well back then in
the 80s they did some research and they
decided that yes there's this huge
reservoir of groundwater beneath us
bigger it you know I guess at Lake Erie
size body of water this is something
called a cross-section and so you're
you're you're cutting the earth in half
and you're looking at it from the side
here's the Sandia's northeast heights
there's the river then there's West Mesa
over here so Rio Rancho is over here
right and this is has what we call a
high vertical exaggeration so you know
how was the distance here it's it's you
know I don't know 10 miles but what is
this distance right one mile from here
to here so it's been vertically
exaggerated much more than the
horizontal scale so point is though they
thought all of this was groundwater down
here and they thought this because they
draw the few they drilled a few wells
and I kept finding groundwater and
they're like oh this is great there's
Lake Erie underneath the ground here but
then they did some more studies after
they published those magazine ads and
they realized that oh actually it's a
pretty small amount of groundwater and
it's really really old like the water
down here is like ten thousand years old
it's left over from the last ice age and
what's it like under say oh I don't know
Rio Rancho a whole lot of nothing and so
all these people are removing hid here
Intel set up Rio Rancho and all that and
they realized oh wait we don't actually
have any groundwater in the groundwater
that we do have we have to drill deeper
and deeper and deeper and our wells are
well over 500 feet deep
to get to groundwater what are we going
to do so on the original 1922 compact
they are entitled to a portion of the
Colorado River water even though as we
said before the Colorado River does not
go through the state of New Mexico but
we're in the watershed so these three
rivers and there's actually a whole
bunch of little ones but these three are
the larger ones these feed in to the San
Juan which this is Navajo dam here but
this is the San Juan River and that
eventually dumps into the Colorado River
and so legally we're entitled to a
portion of the Colorado River water but
we don't have to drill a hole and run a
pipe all the way to the Colorado River
what we can do is we can take water out
of these rivers these tributaries that
feed the Colorado River we can take
water from their second problem how do
we get it to Albuquerque where we need
it well we're on the wrong side of the
Continental Divide so here's the
Continental Divide which is green on
this map I believe it's pink on maybe on
your map so the water naturally wants to
run to the west we needed to get over
here to the east so we're going to use a
trick from Colorado's book and we're
going to drill holes underneath the
mountain and we're going to drop that
water into the Chama River which is then
going to flow down and dump into the Rio
Grande which is then gonna take it all
the way to Albuquerque this is called
the San Juan Chama drinking water
project okay so here's those three
rivers that dump into the San Juan which
dumps into the Colorado we're gonna put
26 miles of tunnels through the
mountains and come out the other side in
dump and there's a couple of little
reservoirs over here along the Chama but
eventually that water gets down and
joins the Rio Grande and then makes its
way
first through Kochi and then eventually
down to Albuquerque so this is what it
looks like on your map I've got this red
line here representing those tunnels San
Juan Chama
diversion okay so it's another train
mountain diversion waters supposed to
land on west of the Continental Divide
but we're going to redirect it east
through the divide and out the other
side with where these tiny little dams
are so unlike California we're not going
to have a big long pipe that goes
hundreds of miles
unlike Arizona we're not going to have
canal that goes hundreds of miles what
we're going to do is we're going to have
tunnels through the mountain but then
we're going to use the natural rivers to
take that water to Albuquerque here's
where the water goes under the mountain
into the tunnels or enters into the
tunnels kind of here's where it comes
out the other side here on Dam and then
eventually it comes all the way down the
Rio Grande and it gets to Albuquerque
does anybody want to drink water out of
the Rio Grande no they do not
so part of this project is you also had
to build a world-class water filtration
system for this water because what's
going to happen is that water comes down
the Rio Grande and we just pump it out
of the river and ultimately we want to
drink this so here's where the what here
comes the water down the Rio Grande
there's a little dam you can't even see
it it goes up and down it's right
through here they raise it up when they
wouldn't take water out they lower it
down when they don't if their Dam is
raised and the fish are coming by and
they can't get around little problem we
got a little fish passage where they can
go around the dam and this is our water
treatment facility and if you're
familiar with Albuquerque it's kind of
round the Renaissance area so there's
like a home depot and stuff around there
big old building but what they're doing
is they're taking all kinds of stuff out
of the water and making it drinkable and
then from there it gets pumped through
throughout the city there's a second
system that takes river water that's not
treated and it takes it to golf courses
and parks all right so don't drink the
water out of the sprinklers because it
may be untreated river water so this was
started you know this project took a
long time to build and and alongside of
that was this big
citywide project to get people to save
water so back in the mid-90s your
average person in Albuquerque was
consuming 250 gallons of water a day now
that's mostly outdoor watering okay so a
lot of this is convincing people that
they don't need these big lush green
lawns but there is a big campaign if you
lived in Albuquerque you may remember
there's lots of billboards about try not
to you know you try to save water try
not to take long showers etc etc and
they got to by 2011 they got there to
their goal of a hundred and fifty
gallons per person per day which just
still seems like a lot if you lined up
150 gallons of water we think I use that
every single day that's all still seems
like a lot compared to the rest of the
world but it's a hundred gallons less
than what we started and so there is a
campaign for that and then we slowly
switched off from the well water to this
the San Juan Chama water and it wasn't
immediate they keep increasing the
proportion of San Juan Chama water so
this is a couple tables of depth to the
water table 538 542 that's how many feet
down you'd have to drill to get to the
water table in a couple of different
areas in Albuquerque and so we see this
kind of bump here over these waves
that's the wet dry wet dry season and
then we see about 2007 is when we start
to transition over we start shutting
these wells down and we see the water
table starting to rebound and you know
it's still 500 feet below the ground
it's gonna take a really really long
time for that to rebound all the way to
where it used to be but point being
because we switched over the San Juan
Chama water our water tables are slowly
starting to rise back up they'll take
decades for them to get back to where
they used to be so what allows us to
stay here in Albuquerque San Juan Chama
project that's what as actually allowing
us to have
water every time we turn that the
faucets on every city in the southwest
has a story right
the reason Phoenix can exist where it
does the reason Las Vegas can exist
where it does the reason Los Angeles can
exist where it does are because these
very major what we call water projects
dams and reservoirs and aqueducts and
canals and tunnels through mountains and
all these things so there's this huge
network of these projects that are
millions and millions and billions of
dollars have been invested to make this
work there's a financial cost there's an
environmental cost right we lost Owens
Lake we lost half a Mono Lake the
Colorado River no longer reaches the
ocean
we've got dams all over the place so
there's an environmental cost for all of
this as well but this is just sort of
basic introduction to the big water
projects that allow us to live in the
driest place in the country
you